- Girl's night!
(gasp) Where are my kids?!
I'm alone.
(children's music plays)
- Okay, let's go over the night:
you can only show two
pictures of your kids tonight
and you can only check-in twice.
- What can I get you?
- I'll get a Howe chardonnay please.
- Yeah, I'll get the same
but can you only fill
it like a fourth full
'cause if I have any more,
I'm just gonna pass out right here.
Yeah, that's good, that's good.
Jackson hasn't pooped
and I just wanted to see if he had yet.
Oh my gosh!
He did it!
Now tell me what color was it?
Was it more of a yellow or a green?
You're not being descriptive enough.
You know what?
Just send me a picture.
Does this look runny to you?
Let me zoom in.
Hold on, look at this.
- Oh, god!
- Does this look runny?
I love this song.
This song Jax and I like
to dance to it like...
- Oh, oh, god.
This is not really...
Don't do that in public.
- What are you looking at?
- You know, actually I'm
looking at, it was my,
you know what?
Come closer.
Come here.
Come on, sit over here.
- Sure.
- It's my son's fourth
birthday party photos.
He looks so cute!
It was circus themed!
So this is his second birthday party
and now it was western themed.
My husband dressed up as a cowboy.
Look at this one.
- Your husband?
- You hungry?
I'm kind of hungry.
- That's not what you bring to a bar.
- If we're drinking,
we have to have snacks!
This has been such a fun night.
I'm gonna head out.
I miss my kids.
I'll see you next month!
- It's only been an hour.
(baby crying)
- I need a break.
Excuse me, would you mind?
Does this look runny to you?
It's my son's poop.